[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Chantal
Hébert bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je veux
revenir sur cette ce contrat qui a été
donné à une firme qui appartient
maintenant au chinois contrat de
télécommunications contrat pour la GRC
donc contrat sensible stratégique on
écoute monsieur Trudeau ce matin qui
remettait le blâme sur les
fonctionnaires et un petit échange en
chambre et on revient tout de suite
on a la responsabilité c'est certain de
tout ce qui se passe au gouvernement et
on l'assume mais la réalité c'est que
des contrats sont pas octroyés par des
politiciens sont octroyés par par des
fonctionnaires qui ont des
responsabilités au niveau de du coup de
la compétence de la sécurité évidemment
les structures qui les entourent et les
paramètres qui existent pour ces
contrats ne sont pas assez adéquates
donc on va on va regarder comment on
peut les renforcer
personne au gouvernement a eu l'idée de
demander au CST de faire une
vérification comment il peut nous
expliquer ça je présente comme j'ai dit
hier nous sommes très préoccupés par
cette situation c'est pour ça qu'on a
demandé au ministre et aux
fonctionnaires de faire des suivis
bon très préoccupé après je le rappelle
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est Margot
qui a révélé ça dans un texte hier matin
sinon sinon rien Chantal
erreur est-ce que vous achetez cet
intérêt juste de fonctionnaire c'est
tout on tourne la page
j'accepte totalement le fait qu'aucun
politicien qui soit donné par quelle
partie au pouvoir serait au courant de
l'octroi d'un contrat de cette dimension
là c'est à dire une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan des contrats et des hauts donc
non il y a personne dans le bureau de
Monsieur Trudeau que jamais vu passer ce
contrat
ce que je crois aussi parce qu'on parle
de la GRC c'est que ça risque d'être un
autre clou dans le cercueil de la
commissaire de GRC parce que ça
s'accumule et c'est ça se passe au même
endroit et l'opposition raison de se
poser des questions sur
quelle partie du message du gouvernement
ça fait quand même plusieurs années
qu'on parle de la Chine des questions
sensibles en matière de sécurité quelle
partie du message c'est pas rendu
jusqu'au fonctionnaire qui ont signé ce
contrôleur
Michel David ouais je suis d'accord avec
Chantal c'était évident que nous
monsieur Trudeau ni personne au cabinet
a vu passer ça
ceci étant dit les critères que Monsieur
ou les paramètres que Monsieur Trudeau
dénonce aujourd'hui et qui sont fixés
par le gouvernement là si je comprends
bien on s'est fié ou on sait conformé à
la règle du plus bas soumissionnaire il
y avait une entreprise du Québec qui
choses à faire la job mais c'était un
peu plus cher alors quand on fait ça il
y a des effets pervers on l'avait vu au
Québec avec la commission Campo
Charbonneau
le plus bas soumissionnaire ça a donné
lieu à toutes sortes de collusions là
qu'on a dénoncé pendant des mois mais là
l'effet pervers c'est que on se fie
juste au plus bas prix puis on se fout
des autres considérations y compris la
sécurité écoutez notre collègue godbou
est un homme très perspicace mais mais
je comprends pas que si un journaliste a
pu découvrir que cette ferme-là était
détenue en partie par des intérêts
chinois on n'a pas découvert ça à Ottawa
alors là il y a des coups de pied
derrière qui qui se perdent c'est clair
ouais Véronique moi je comprends pas non
plus pourquoi un responsable des marchés
publics fédéraux aurait répondu
justement à notre collègue Margotte boue
que la sécurité nationale cette
question-là avait pas été prise en
compte dans l'attribution du contrat
pourquoi alors que il y a des drapeaux
rouges des agences de sécurité
concernant les ingérences dans nos
institutions et on parle aussi de d'une
sécurisation d'un système de
communication alors c'est clair qui a
beaucoup de questions sans réponse ça
devrait être clair si les deux temps que
le que l'entreprise qui aurait pu avoir
le contrat qui qui demandait 60000
dollars de plus qui est dans la région
de Montréal sur la Rive-Sud le directeur
disait à la question gay à la radio ce
midi il dit
ultimement l'entreprise a des codes
secrets qui font qu'on peut écouter
effectivement les communications
secrètes de la GRC dans ce que c'est oui
les codes c'est pas se poser d'avoir pas
beaucoup d'employés ont accès mais bon
alors bref il y avait un côté sensible
OK
prochain sujet la chasse c'est pas la
perdrix est-ce que c'est la perdrix
donc monsieur faitgaben depuis 20 ans se
rend avec des amis du lac Manfre Magog
donc demander des gens d'affaires riches
et qui ont une île privée
à la chasse au faiseur depuis 20 ans là
il est ministre aurait-il dû ne pas y
aller le dire pas le dire à Montréal
avait ça ce matin en une réaction de
Monsieur fitzgerbin monsieur Legault
l'opposition peut on revient
de voir les bonnes connaissances que
j'ai
manqué de jugement en allant à la chasse
dans ce cul privé il est allé à la
chasse donc pour vous c'est pas un
problème d'éthique il est allé à la
chasse
il y a des questions à se poser sur une
apparence de conflit d'intérêt et en ce
sens là on retrouve la même des
évolution du ministre que l'on connaît
depuis ces dernières années enfin que
c'est Monsieur Gabin qui a encore une
fois à l'éthique assez slack monsieur
Fès
qui n'est plus dans le monde des
affaires qu'il est un serviteur de
l'État maintenant et qu'y a-t-il
rencontré parce que je doute qu'il se
soit déguisé tout seul en costume
d'époque pour chasser tout seul du
faisan qui rencontrait-il donc
évidemment que ça prend une enquête puis
des réponses à ce niveau-là
Véronique vous êtes à Québec vous avez
vu ça dans les couloirs les réactions
qu'est-ce qu'on en dit puis est-ce que
d'après vous parce que lui il dit que la
commissaire analytique face en quête je
l'invite à faire en quête d'ailleurs
mais d'ailleurs là-dessus moi je sens un
changement de ton parce que dans le
premier mandat pierre faitgaben se
défendait il se justifie en expliquant
que vous savez ça fait tellement
longtemps que je suis à l'affaire que
c'est sûr que mes amis sont des hommes
d'affaires je peux pas me faire des
nouveaux amis c'est sûr que je vais
garder mon entourage puis on doit vivre
avec là je trouve qu'il n'essaye plus de
se justifier c'est comme si l'assumait
que il y aura toujours probablement des
demandes d'enquête parce que les
journalistes vont continuer de gratter
les parties de position vont continuer
de gratter tant que c'est pas immoral ou
illégal il connaît maintenant le
processus de la commissaire alexique et
au contraire on voit qu'il souhaite
qu'elle fasse en quête parce qu'il se
dit ben si ça peut faire la lumière puis
démontrer que finalement j'étais pas
fautif là-dedans mais qu'elle le fasse
alors je sens qu'il a un assumer et je
sens qu'au bureau du premier ministre
aussi c'est assumer qui va y avoir
d'autres histoires comme ça qui vont
sortir c'est sûr que ça leur fait pas
plaisir ça fait pas leur affaire mais
comme je le disais tant que c'est pas
immoral et illégal mais ça les a pas
empêché de nommer pierre Fitz Gabin
super ministre et ça demeure quand même
à leurs yeux un des ministres les plus
populaires de leur gouvernement
Michel David qui soutient debout dit
c'est comme ça si vous avez un problème
prouvez-moi qu'un vrai problème sinon
moi je vais continuer à faire ça ouais
mais là ça me dépense ce qu'on appelle
un problème je pense pas que quelque
chose d'illégal je pense pas que je me
suis fait ce Gabon a profité de sa
partie de chasse là pour négocier des
subventions il peut rencontrer ces
gens-là n'importe où n'importe quand
c'est pas ça l'idée là c'est
politiquement on a vu le monsieur
monsieur Legault là il n'était pas
content il est pas content qu'il y a
raison parce que les gens vont dire
encore fait du début mais il y a dessus
des maudites les mettre à tripoter puis
à mélanger les gens la politiquement
c'est très mauvais et Monsieur fait du
Québec il s'en fout c'est il s'en dit
toujours foutu puis là il s'en fout
encore donc vous vous dites c'est un
problème Michel vous dites aller à la
chasse sur une île privée donc c'est
l'équivalent de recevoir c'est un
problème de perception je pense pas que
qui est en conflit d'intérêt mais ça
donne une mauvaise idée et en plus c'est
bon c'est conjoncturel mais vous savez
le moment où il y a des fils dans les
banques alimentaires là puis là le
ministre le s'en va chasser le faisant
avec son son habit autrichien là ça fait
ça paraît mal Chantal
entendons-nous que pour un ministre ce
qui veut prêcher la sobriété énergétique
à la majorité des Québécois qui ont pas
nécessairement les moyens de la
pratiquer ou qu'il a pratiqué parce que
ça coûte trop cher ça lui enlève
beaucoup d'autorité morale il faudrait
pas non plus que quelqu'un trouve des
photos tous ces gens en costumes c'est
quoi autrichien parce que là la
crédibilité prend un coup c'est sûr
aussi Michel a raison que François
Legault voulait pas le jour de la mise à
jour budgétaire de son gouvernement être
pris à parler de l'achat au faisant de
son ministre à l'économie ça envoie tous
les mauvais messages et c'est pas une
question de conflit d'intérêt c'est une
question d'image et de d'autorité morale
et tout ça diminue l'autorité Montréal
du ministre mais c'est vrai que
là-dessus il commence quand même à y
avoir une accumulation et qu'à la fin
qu'il y ait blanc ou non de la
commissaire alexique ça colle quand même
justement à la peau de pierrefitgiben et
il se fait talonner il va encore se
faire talonner et finalement il va
conserver l'image de quelqu'un peut-être
qui entretient des liens trop à trop
avec ses amis dans le milieu des
affaires donc comme je vous disais je
sens ça il dit c'est juste je vais
continuer à avoir des liens 3 je suis là
pour
[Musique]
ok alors on verra mais lui c'est
intéressant que quand vous dites il y a
un changement d'attitude il ne va plus
s'excuser jusqu'au moment où peut-être
il devra choisir autre chose
c'est une drôle d'histoire encore à
Québec les factures symboliques de
Monsieur Dubé ils jongle avec l'idée
d'envoyer aux contribuables la facture
de ce que ça a coûté une intervention
chirurgicale ou une intervention à
l'hôpital on écoute
vous avez écouté 8000 dollars vous avez
écouté 16000 dollars et la facture c'est
zéro et vous êtes capable de voir
qu'est-ce que d'avoir cette gratuité là
c'est universalité là c'est ça notre
gros avantage au Québec et qu'elle
serait pas le plaisir et le bonheur d'un
citoyen de dire je viens de recevoir un
beau cadeau 18000 pièces parce que j'ai
fait charger mes deux hanches puis ça
m'a rien coûté c'est ça le principe
d'universalité
écoutez l'énergie qui va être mis
là-dedans j'aimerais mieux qu'on le
mette à servir en première ligne les
patients qui attendent après le service
puis vous le voyez là ça peut être de
partout on sent quoi bon envoyer des
factures symboles qu'est-ce que c'est
pour culpabiliser les gens ça change
quoi quel est le but de ça pourquoi
arriver avec ça maintenant ce que c'est
pour faire diversion sur les histoires
de pizza de toast et autres il y aura
pas de problème générés par une
initiative comme celle-là où est-ce
qu'on prend conscience des coût réels
c'est simplement difficile de comprendre
pourquoi en ce moment alors qu'on est
vraiment dans une situation de crise
cette facture fictive là devient une
priorité
alors que on n'arrive pas à donner des
services de hanche à ceux qui en ont
besoin à tous ceux qui en ont besoin en
tout cas Chantal qu'en pensez-vous
d'abord que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on entend cette idée là on l'a
entendu dans Michel doit s'en souvenir
là dans des
précédentes de parler de santé ensuite
qu'on imagine que ça va venir avec un
rappel au ministre que les Québécois
payent des impôts quand même pour avoir
les services auxquels ils ont droit j'ai
de la misère à imaginer que quelqu'un
serait contrairement à Monsieur dubuil
de la misère à boire la démarche où
quelqu'un qui regarderait ça après avoir
attendu deux ou trois ans pour avoir son
service serait reconnaissant plutôt que
de se dire qu'il y en a vraiment pas
pour son argent parce que on lui dit tu
devrais te considérer chanceux on s'est
occupé de toi même si tu avais pas les
moyens nécessairement de payer pour ça
je pense que c'est une très mauvaise
bonne idée
c'est une très mauvaise bonne idée
écoutez d'abord c'est pas un cadeau là
de 18000 pièces on paye une assurance
c'est si vous payez une assurance chaque
année une fois vous avez un accident de
voiture vous êtes remboursé à valeur à
neuf ah quel beau cadeau non non c'est
pas un cadeau vous avez pour cette
assurance là les Québécois payent pour
l'assurance maladie à même leurs impôts
d'autre part oui chantal a raison c'est
pas nouveau et je me souviens moi c'est
je l'ai retrouvé c'est dans une
un projet de réforme de marquant côté en
décembre 90 on proposait exactement la
même chose c'est une facture annuelle
alors tout ce qu'on avait pris comme
traitement dans soi dans des cliniques
soit dans des établissements publics on
avait
la liste au bout de l'année et le but à
l'époque c'était parce que c'était en
même temps que jonglais avec l'idée d'un
ticket modérateur c'était de freiner
trouver un moyen de freiner un peu la
consommation cette fois-ci je suis pas
certain que c'est ça qui est l'objectif
mon impression c'est que il y a
tellement de mécontentement autour de
tous les projets de réforme puis des
services puis des listes d'attente puis
de tout ce que vous devez en santé que
là le ministre essaie de me dire voyez
on va on va leur donner quelque chose
qui va prouver qu'il y a toujours un bon
ça va bien et puis finalement alors
c'est une opération de politique
purement alors je vois pas du tout et
c'est honnêtement je trouve ça un peu
indécent ouais Véronique donc on sent
que ça va peut-être pas voler très haut
là mais c'est vrai que c'est un fantasme
des ministères du ministre de la santé
depuis vraiment des années parce que
guitare barrette en parler aussi je
demande la possibilité et d'ailleurs il
avait mis en place justement des travaux
là-dessus que Christian Dubé sur
lesquels Christian du base finalement
peut-être que c'est au niveau de la
communication parce que là on l'axe
beaucoup sur le patient va savoir ce qui
coûte finalement puis il va se trouver
chanceux pas le payer de sa poche et moi
ce qu'on m'a expliqué aussi c'est quand
même temps l'avantage de ça c'est aussi
peut-être de voir un hôpital
combien il a chargé l'année dernière ça
nous permet de voir à quelle hauteur on
doit le financer mais là on l'aurait
pour cette année on aurait davantage les
chiffres en temps réel donc c'est
factures là servirait pas juste aux
patient finalement mais aussi
investissement des hôpitaux alors c'est
peut-être ce côté-là qui doit venir
expliquer pour que les gens puissent
comprendre la nécessité mais j'ai pas
besoin d'une facture pour que le
ministère de la Santé sache combien un
acte a coûté d'autre part je ferai
curieuse de savoir sur l'impact sur la
vie privée parce que ça va passer par où
la facture des soins dont moi j'ai eu
besoin pas convaincu non plus
ok merci beaucoup c'est tout le temps
qu'on a merci à vous trois bonnes
soirées à très bientôt au revoir au
revoir au revoir